the upcoming butterfly effect of Bert
kreiser's new movie The Machine may be a
lot more significant than anyone quite
understands leading up to the premiere
including Bert stand-up comedian
starring in box office movies is
obviously not new from Jim Carrey's
insane stretch of Classics in the early
90s Kevin Hart's recent run of huge
comedy films or even Andrew Schultz's
appearance in the remake of White Men
Can't Jump plenty of comedians have been
hired to act on the big screen but never
before has a studio taken quite as large
of a chance on a comic like Sony is
right now on Bert Kreischer and his new
movie The Machine the story that was
made famous 12 years ago as the closing
joke in Birds act and has been performed
in front of audiences all around the
world is now just two days away from
being released in movie form